et puis enfin j'aimerais vous présenter
un pur génie est quelqu'un dont un jour
le cerveau reposera dans le formol et on
le montre raul c'est quand même faut le
dire c'est bertrand renard bat warner
vous le voyez est derrière cette
moustache se cache une mécanique
intellectuelle inouïe sa musique depuis
un an et demi
répond à toutes les questions qu'on lui
pose nous dans l'équipe genre
l'anniversaire d'appel sais qui c'était
quand il répond on s'est dit c'est trop
facile vous montrer tout de suite par
exemple saint john perse date de
naissance 31 mai 1887 il est mort en
1975 le 20 septembre le mahatma gandhi
d'octobre 1929 30 janvier 1948 philippe
séguin c'était hier son anniversaire il
est 46 ans jean paul belmondo à c'était
il ya treize jours son anniversaire il a
eu 56 109 alors c'est très agaçant
on s'est dit qu'on pouvait jouer avec
vous alors j'ai fait a organisé une
espèce de de jeu minitel et catherine
ménages et nous organiser tous elle
s'occupe du minitel chez nous et vous
pouvez tout ce temps que vous êtes lui
poser des questions vous croyez
peut-être passé comme ça mais sauter sur
votre minitel et demandez-lui des dates
qui vous paraissent impossibles ou qui
paraissent peut-être possible
vous verrez c'est extraordinaire il sait
répondre c'est un petit peu pareil
heures je les connais pas date et heure
de naissance de jeanne moreau 23 janvier
1928 l'heure je ne sais pas je sais pas
forcément les heures et bruyant 5
décembre 1922 à bien
mathilda may lead et 8 février 1965 la
donne elle est beaucoup plus jeune que
fit la jupe et 15 août 45 alors plein de
minitel encore pour battre un renard à
date de naissance de hitler c'est facile
oui ça c'est et y est c'est à dire
soutenir georges harrison 25 février 43
celle des beatles thomas ce mot à 7
février 14 60 18 mai dit de oui cela
jean paul ii jean paul ii 18 mai 1901
neil armstrong c'est le cosmonaute 5930
des imac auteur de science fiction
ah oui il est mort récemment il est né
le 3 août 19 prévus sur la couverture de
20 jours flaubert 12 décembre 10 ans de
jeanne d'arc 14 112 alors elle est née
le 6 janvier ça c'est pas très sympa
claude louis 29 août 1929 il est plus
jeune française traduit son directeur 31
mai
oh là là et 40 je crois quelque chose
comme ça te fâcher avec lui parce que si
les plus vieux toute façon sur un go 20
octobre 1854 villon et 14 131 on sait
pas son jour va laisser les bassines
l'état civil n'existait pas à l'époque
bien sûr léon zitrone 25 novembre 1914
claude monet 14 novembre 1840 il ya 180
plus que le prince charles georges
brassens 22 octobre 1921 ça c'est facile
mare a mare à 24 1743 j'ajoute charlotte
corday dont j'avais accordé 27 8 768
général mangin amant jeu 6 juillet 10 66
- de raspoutine raspoutine l'édifiant 71
là aussi on sait pas son jour quand même
une de plus que dorée t il et il est
vraiment malade moi je peux vous le dire
je le connais j'ai un côté il se balance
toute la journée comme ça rapidement la
paire actrices d'iran soraya 23,8 chose
9 octobre 1859
elton john 25 mars quand tu es quand il
mord lénine le 21 janvier 1920 il était
né là le 22 avril 10 70 solidaire en
notre calendrier car c'était le 10 avril
en calendrier merci jean marie 20 juin
1928 et laurent cabrol 13 mai 1900 il
m'a dit 47 je crois que jacques chirac
vous 32 c'est enfantin cervantes
cervantes 14 157 29 septembre vous
dormez un peu la nuit à 147 j'avais fait
457 15/40 c'est comme dans rain man
c'est l'image qui vient quoi oui c'est
nous tous je peux vous le dire
à l'origine cervantes n'est pas dans le
gilles lalay gilles allais je sais pas
qui c'est et tracteurs du paris dakar
ainsi du sport
[Musique]